get ready cause we're coming at you fast
and ferocious with this week's picks you
thought I was gonna say Furious didn't
you why didn't I along with the return
of the popular car Centric action
franchise we're stepping on the gas with
movies about a gardener a dominatrix a
couple of Mario Brothers and a giant
lizard wow that sounds like the
beginning of a really bad joke but nope
it's just this week's what to watch
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gone behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today speeding
into theaters is the action adventure
film fast X reason number one to see
this is that it's the beginning of the
end of the road for the fast Saga with
plans to reach the Finish Line with fast
11 due out in 2025. however Vin Diesel
did tease a possible fast 12 at this
film's red carpet Premiere in Rome so
this could become a finale Trilogy
reason 2 is Jason Momoa joining the cast
as a villain named Dante Reyes spoiler
alert the son of a drug lord who was
killed in 2011's Fast Five and Dante's
thirst for Revenge has Vin Diesel's Dom
fighting to protect his crew and his
family in this film I'm Diesel and Momoa
yes please and a fast film wouldn't be
complete without some jaw-dropping
surprises all the way through including
some at the end of the film so be sure
to stay past the credits there's one
thing you don't talk about
what's up yourself
[Music]
there's not much to know also pruning
its way into theaters is the Indie crime
Thriller Master Gardener no it's not
just a metaphorical title because this
film stars Joel Edgerton as an actual
meticulous horticulturalist at a
beautiful estate he's forced to take on
the owner's troubled great niece as an
apprentice and then things begin to
unravel Edgerton is joined by Sigourney
Weaver and quintessa swindle as well
making this talented cast the main
reason to check it out plus it was
written and directed by Paul Schroeder
who wrote a little old film called Taxi
Driver Once Upon a Time among other
Martin Scorsese projects so yeah the
dude knows his stuff Master Gardener
made its World premiere at the Venice
Film Festival last fall and critics have
been enjoying it to the tune of a fresh
68 on the Tomato Meter which definitely
doesn't take a meticulous
horticulturalist to run just a bunch of
crazies you know this job your new role
the company a CEO yeah it's a really big
deal this is not a good idea to keep
doing this
another theoretical option this week is
the dark comedy thriller Sanctuary this
one may be worth adding to your watch
list for the simple fact that it's a
unique single location film that takes
place over the course of one night and
it stars just two people Christopher
Abbott and Margaret quality he plays the
heir to a hotel Empire who battles it
out with the dominatrix who helped Prime
him for Success played by quali as he
tries to end the relationship director
zagary wiggin is a relative newcomer to
the biz but the film's screenplay was
penned by Micah Bloomberg best known as
the co-creator of the hit series
homecoming after premiering at the
Toronto International Film Festival this
one has been a hit with critics and its
fresh 97 score on the Tomato meaner is
backed by reviews from people like top
critic David erlich from Indy wire who
called it a salaciously enjoyable slice
of snack sized fun there's a huge
Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us jumping
levels from theaters to streaming this
week on Voodoo 2 is the Super Mario
Brothers movie this animated Juggernaut
has a strong 96 audience score that is
backed by its 1.1 billion dollar Hall at
the global box office that's good enough
to make this the highest grossing film
based on a video game like ever and the
highest grossing film of 2023. you go
Mario all your favorite characters from
the game show up in this one courtesy of
a stellar cast that includes Chris Pratt
as Mario and Charlie day as Luigi plus
Keegan Michael Key Anya Taylor Joy Jack
Black and Seth Rogen and in a year that
has been relatively scarce when it comes
to options for kids this movie provided
some major relief for parents with a
trip to theaters and it can now do the
same with a trip to the couch that's
okay kids can play outside later kids
still do that right
foreign
and finally because celebrating 25 years
of Rotten Tomatoes is our favorite thing
to do around here our rt25 pick this
week is 1998's Godzilla released 25
years ago this week and marking the 23rd
film in the Godzilla franchise this one
Stars Matthew Broderick because nothing
says sci-fi action thriller like Matthew
Broderick just kidding we love you
Maddie the film was directed and
co-written by Roland emmerich who was
coming off Independence Day a couple of
years prior and would go on to cement
himself as the disaster film King with
projects like the day after tomorrow and
White House Down Godzilla may be rotten
on the Tomato meaner but I'm pretty sure
there's not a Nostalgia setting on that
thing so whatever this one is worth a
look 25 years later no matter how you
slice it or smash it
well there you have it fresh folks five
fantastic films to fill up your week be
sure to let us and your fellow viewers
know in the comments what you did check
out whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rotten
tomatoes.com for the latest updates on
scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large and seriously check out
the new rt25 page where we're
celebrating 25 years of Rotten Tomatoes
you don't want to be the one who misses
out on the party do you do you that's
all for today fresh family until next
week stay fresh
foreign